basic principles nari should know woman
wakes up saying god I hope I don't get
swept off my feet today sure but it's
also true that no woman ever wakes up
saying I hope I don't eat an amazing
burrito today that doesn't mean I walk
around lower Manhattan with a bag of
Taco Bell at the ready to foist my
burrito on them I'm really into my
career right now you believe that
neither does she
well this movie hasn't aged well at all
it's not a bad time for her she doesn't
need any space oh and here all this time
I've been treating women as independent
humans with their own set of concerns
when really it was all about me the
whole time thanks fourth wall breaking
sexist Will Smith 60% of all human
communication is nonverbal 30% is your
tone so that means that 90% ain't coming
out of your mouth but you just said
thirty percent was tone were you talking
about skin tone muscle tone because I'm
pretty sure of vocal tone falls clearly
in the coming out of the mouth
Department now the key tonight is hang
back give her plenty of space and now
we've shifted to the direct
instructional part no explanation of why
hitch was talking directly to us for the
first three minutes just jumping into
bits and pieces of three separate dudes
getting there Smith and lesson about how
to women can't believe I'm saying this
but can we just get to Kevin James
already just don't be looking at her
mouth
don't be wondering what she looks like
naked listen these students are paying
this guy top dollar here for this advice
all of a sudden we're on date number two
he is way too obviously paranoid here to
have ever made it out of date number one
a lot in case you didn't go to high
school hitting is a good thing oh my god
he's back to breaking the fourth wall
and this is the fastest I've ever wanted
to bail on a movie and I need this to
end three days is all I need three dates
and I'll get you here to the high stakes
medal round the three dates I realize
Hollywood is out of touch with us
regular folks but you 100% absolutely
cannot pace every successful
relationship the same way much less call
all of them success or failure at the
3:15 date eight out of ten women believe
that the first kiss will tell them
everything they need to know about the
relationship citation needed did you
only pull middle-schoolers for this
movies getting all of its statistics
from Cosmo after that you're on your own
great so you can help them get a girl
and then you abandon them because you
have no real skills in relationships
marriage counselors are cheaper than you
and do a more noble service I'm just
saying it's just kind of evil Fargo
clover design this couch can just write
the hell off and enjoy hipster eternity
see if these are in focus will yeah and
having my desk in an hour
developing films were a realist
masquerading as a cynic who is secretly
an optimist so the glass is secretly
half-full if it exists at all
I'm sorry I just can't understand
personalities unless they're
communicated via liquid in container
ratios fun dirt the snowstorm
well yeah because dirt is brown and the
snow is white now finding dirt and
sandstorm that's a different story you
know your problem is hitch you're all
about the short game well maybe but
you're the one playing billiards well
making a golf analogy all of us are not
married to the woman of our dreams and
about to have a baby I believe you mean
not all of us instead of all of us are
not unless you are suggesting that no
one is married to the woman of their
dreams and about to have a baby in which
case Prince Harry is on the line with
some suitable words for you you need to
listen to me man I'm serious
this isn't acting this is Michael
Rapaport daily affirmation hey did you
ever hear this guy they call the date
doctor imagine the sins I'd remove if
this thing would end right here
some guys naturally develop a comfort
with the opposite sex back in college I
was just not one of them flashback the
situation nerdy Will Smith is only
slightly more believable than ugly
Rachel Leigh cook and she's all that
also how do you know he's nerdy and
unpopular he wears glasses
he drops books you know the only total
morons ever dude her name was Cressida
Baylor who named this poor girl after a
pastry and my life would never be the
same wait did she just heal his vision
with her hotness because with no guile
and no game there's no girl seriously
how many times do we need to see Alex
getting piggy with it before we get the
point he's damn near beyond redemption
already in a movie that doesn't ever
even attempt to redeem it and if ever
there was a man born without game it was
Albert Brennaman
the way this movie introduces characters
and gives backstory feels like it comes
from a children's picture books like
someone crossed the rules with good
night boom I was about to give this
movie newspaper articles some credit but
then I realized it was repeating itself
definitely been hurt a lot you know I
had a lot of bad experiences he's
talking about pixels nobody gives us a
full seven seconds of Kevin James's ass
and I can't help but take it personally
you know it's like getting up every
morning feeling hopeless feel like the
love of your life is waking up with the
wrong man given your razor thin tie to
the woman in question
this just makes you sound like an
obsessed stalker yes hitch No
what that feels like but with hitch that
girl he couldn't get anymore at least
did originally know it and even kiss it
Michelangelo Sistine Chapel this is such
a bad analogy it's a borderline straw
man argument Michelangelo painted a
great work on the ceiling of the Sistine
Chapel you are about to turn Albert from
a doofus into a likable boyfriend apples
called and screamed stop comparing me to
oranges you ignorant prick why not a
Cyrano de Bergerac reference or even
Michelangelo's David a sculpture he had
to carve out of a large mass of marble
taken literally your analogy suggests
that you were going to paint a great
work of art on the inside ceiling of
Albert skull and that's gross can we
just agree this dude probably never gets
to date one with the celebrity hottie
this movie paints him as accident-prone
as Chevy Chase is Gerald Ford for
Christ's sake he's practically mr. bean
[Music]
person forgets they're wearing pants
even though that would never happen
because humans are keenly aware of bare
skin cliche well looks like I'm still
red jokes rich people make what I was
wondering is if I could have $500,000 to
invest on my own script bull here no
celebrity of her stature would ever be
this meek or we'd even ask to access
their own money but because the movie
wants Kevin James to point that fact out
it makes a leg road wilting flower here
it's kind of sexist if you think about
it but I'm not here to call off this
movie so you bet your ass I'm here to
call it this movie sexism because it is
and this is only one tiny example of it
what is the object of shock and awe this
discount Pygmalion Korea is testing my
patience what's up with these empty
bowls even if it's not a snacky kind of
meeting there is no way fancy financial
firm wouldn't have some sort of
something in them bag of Red Delicious
apples is like five bucks for pete's
sake do you have a pen as cute as this
pen reverse pickpocket is unless Will
Smith retained his Hancock x-ray vision
he has no way of knowing if she's
looking or not
Oh me a micro the problem with movies
like this is that the second day tried
to say anything deeper about gender
equality you remember all that bull
female baiting at the beginning of the
movie actually worked but then he'd ask
her name and what she did for a living
this meta conversation tada tete is
actually clever interesting when fun
which makes me think what if this was
just a drama where hitch battles his own
demons of manipulation and womanizing or
just an over-the-top pratfall comedy
where he helps Kevin James learn how to
let his inner truth escape his clumsy
exterior I'm not sure it needs to do
both no I'm not even sure it can do both
as much crap as we give fight scenes
where the bad guys fight one at a time
the same thing happens in movie
conversations too this best friend just
happens to arrive at the exact moment
hitchhikes away it's raining convenience
yes I'm fine
excuse me in a second I get that Alex
may not like to hear it so plainly
stated but certainly he can't be
surprised that this is how some men
would see his work pitch please a full
minute of jet ski montage this movie is
in no hurry to do anything whatsoever I
am NOT taking it well
it's Marty hitch since when does she
know him as hitch this is the first time
she's seeing him since he introduced
himself as Alex Hitchens you know what I
think I think she knows the title of the
movie she's in over 100 million
Americans can trace their ancestry back
to a single man as we continue into the
Ellis Island informational portion of
the movie I just remembered that Kevin
James used to be in this remember that
guy first date he hasn't even revealed
the signature of your dead murderous
ancestor yet but yes this movie came out
in 2000 and way after this joke was tire
women like Allegra Cole don't pick up
numbers they don't recognize okay she
does pick up but forget that for a
moment women like her have assistants
Manning their phones right precisely to
prevent PR disasters like what happens
after Allegra picks up this phone
hilarious gag aside why does nerdo
Albert Brennaman have so many ping lines
in the first place
Rumi that Batman well great great and
more pratfalls someone call 911 I think
he's having a heart attack so this is an
opportunity to break the touch barrier
sleazy way leaned in place your hand on
the small of her back just a heads up
I've double-checked with all my double
ex friends and it doesn't get much
lesser than an unwelcome touch in the
small of the back so take everything
hitch is saying here with a green a bull
a woman's best friend has to sign off on
all big relationship decisions
this movie is sneakily almost as
misogynistic is what women want
ACK thanks
this entire exchange is frustrating for
a bunch of reasons this guy has earned
and vase the out of this room there are
more urns and vases here than chairs or
lamps start the fire I make the pizza
cute movie never even called me to ask
if they could use the broom dance that I
made up and that would have played way
better than the pizza or the q-tip hich
slapped Albert grinds on Allegra here
because the power of boners is stronger
than actual character traits and date
awkwardness Knicks fan good when they're
good man she was there wait a second
doesn't that story say it was written by
her how she surprised by an article that
she herself wrote I can't wait to read
all about the sports final did the one
team beat the other team by an
undetermined amount of scoring units max
is getting really irritated
Koff New York you are not small enough a
city that her boss would be standing
next to her at this random newsstand go
eat a poison just one says no one dance
one look one kiss that's all we get
Albert false or else you'd both be gone
but instead he gets to see Allegra again
and you get to mentor him again
just one shot do not miss your chance to
blow cuz opportunity comes once in a
lifetime you've no more games or more
change what you call rage tear this
motherfuckin roof off like two dogs cake
oh sorry whoa I got off on an M&M
tangent there eight out of ten women
believe that the first kiss will tell
them everything that they need to know
about a relationship skip a woman that
doesn't want to kiss takes the keys out
puts him in the door goes in a house a
woman that wants the kiss she fiddles
Jesus in a juicy jambalaya
tickets went to some guy named Alex
Hitchens if he's trying to keep his
business a secret why would he ever send
a client and a famous girl to a party
under his real name also there are a lot
of people in New York right because the
fact that she just happened to be
pursuing a story on Eleni that one of
his clients was wooing and her best
friend just happened to be
hit on by another perspective client
we've met makes me feel like Manhattan
is may be occupied by about 27 people
and you had a dryclean did you also take
it to a master tailor as well because
that shirt most definitely ripped clean
off when he got it caught in the cab
speak English hitch does every fool in
this movie automatically call him hitch
the first time they meet him I refuse to
roll credits on the basis of your silly
falsi tunes I think you have food
allergies does he not know about the
moon is this news to him I'm asking for
real which was out too big too low I
both love and hate retail workers I've
been there but also when I was there I
was nicer than this no actually benadryl
is only helpful for relieving allergies
symptoms like itching for severe food
allergy reactions which his puffy ass
face sure seems to be pendulum moves too
slowly to be helpful but a way to sell
some benadryl a movie I bet I can ask
you just about anything right now
yeah but benadryl is not a truth serum
or even out of the Hall for that matter
it may make you drowsy and put you out
but I highly doubt it would create this
level of loopiness she's 100% taking
advantage of his inebriation right now
and abusing their friendship in pursuit
of a celebrity gossip story wait does he
have a large set of floor-to-ceiling
blinds perpendicular to the wall and not
covering any window like blinds as a
half wall the lets room was definitely
over decorated Christ
he upped and married my sister really
have a baby he has the balls to name its
sequel two thirds of the way through its
own original last runtime write you any
siblings this movie's tagline could have
been it goes on for some time
um we're skating on the pond at her
house and she fell through the ice
no one will be seated during that It's a
Wonderful Life portion of the movie
longest three minutes of my life this is
exactly what my college girlfriend said
to me after our first time okay who are
you and what have you done with my best
friend who are you and what have you
done with cliche movie reluctantly
admits that at least half of what it's
putting on a screen is a bunch of bull
man getting his hair waxed off and it's
painful hilarious and original and
hilarious and original and hilarious but
tomorrow I'm free alright so a second
ago he invited her to dinner at his
place another hanging up but she does
not know where he lives
ooh he took her to a fucking Knicks game
just spill hot coffee on her and call
her a whore great seats great game well
if by a great game you mean Stephon
Marbury leading all scorers with a
whopping 23 points in a 14 point loss to
the perennial powerhouse Memphis
Grizzlies man sure great game
look I know it all works out okay but
albert is so fucking anxious right now I
feel like hitch sucks at his job except
his job seems to be tricking women
rather than actively building up men so
maybe he's great at his job but his job
sucks
Allegra yes guess I won't be needing
this anymore incoming
really yep shakin hands there's no
universe in which a reporter this eager
for a story would have her back turned
on what was happening let alone for this
long except the universe where a
scriptwriter wanted to play a visual
version of the pronoun game for maximum
dramatic effect while at the same time
giving a double scorpion punch to
reality how'd you get my card
Albert Albert Brennaman now hold onto
your Hitchcock there a second movie
how did they even know Albert is using
the date doctor the only reason they're
following the brennaman story is because
he's dating Allegra Cole and if somehow
they guessed that he had used the date
doctor even though no one has mentioned
that wouldn't that already appointed her
towards Alex since the tickets came from
him hitch okay fine roll hitch it's
already I'm gonna check on the risotto
if you left risotto unattended for this
long then you've done dump watch Top
Chef bitch salad tossing you know what I
can't really talk right now if Albert
just got taken down by the NYPD how did
he even have a chance to answer the
phone and if they let him answer the
phone why wouldn't they let him finish
the call list attainments a lot women
will remain seated men will rotate to
the left at the buzzer this is so much
like my first sleepover it's spooky holy
how many things in common two hitch and
40 year old virgin have both came out in
2005 and have a nerdy lead who has
little experience with women both
feature scenes with a man getting his
hair waxed off while he screams
pop-culture references both have a speed
dating scene where the main characters
disrupt an entire speed-dating event
both movies end with an elaborate full
cast dance party
they never even replaced him on the
board is the empty chair symbolic point
out here a new financial guy is it for
the shop I bet it's for the shop I made
some assumptions about you based on
nothing it turns out or may be based on
an accurate assessment of his actions
considering he offers men the ability to
manipulate women into relationships
without any ability to know what their
true motives are the fact that the movie
wants to absolve hich so badly that he
never wrestles with any of the
underlying issues or consequences of
what he does for a living and makes the
women the ones who need to apologize for
being too difficult to attain is
repulsive and worth at least 30 cents
fuckin hich man selling the stuff you
just don't believe in your own product
thing I say every day into the mirror
somehow it makes it into the final cut
of the movie Wow the tide lowers fast in
New York City because she's clearly
walking up to the boat from this angle
and then it's even here then when hitch
leaves a couple minutes later it's
already at least a foot below the dock
almost like they shot this over the
course of several hours instead of five
minutes my job is not to deceive miss
Cole it's to create opportunities
hello semantics collect call from Alex
Hitchens will you accept the charges
maybe it's like what you said we should
just both go our separate ways and do
just fine this movie wishes it had the
balls to pull off this ending what do
you think you are lamb remember that
bull at the beginning about no means
just try harder who if he just wants to
make sure you know it's doubling down
this is like the spider-man 3 of
romantic comedies too much everything
[Applause]
remember when Will Smith used to do
original rap songs for all his movies
why'd he stop doing that I got robbed of
some classics man like happiness with a
why you and I I'm gonna get a job even
if I don't have a tie or after Earth we
left him than the Earth's of birth haha
and now I gotta teach my son has worked
or else we'll never have some month or
for this movie it could be hitch hitch
don't call her a bitch it's a difficult
since she's rich but you glitch oh maybe
I see why stop excuse me I'd like to ask
you a few questions actually I got a
little sick yeah bullets over Broadway
was on TV I came down with a big old
Dianne Wiest infection what is the
objective shock and awe what is the
objective yeah you did it with flair all
right
there's my flare no Kelly Clarkson
hold it hold it what is this
they trying to trick me